thank you we are here with one of the
winners of today's round actually the
very important game here jordan van
forest has won against lanier dominguez
jordan i was telling the viewers winning
a game of chess that's hard but
surprisingly near dominguez in the
opening man that's almost impossible and
you did it with this move a3 tell us how
it came about yeah i thought it
might be interesting like for rapid game
it's kind of innocuous but
um for rapid game i mean white doesn't
risk a whole lot and if like goes wrong
you might get a small advantage with
white and kind of for rapid game i
didn't want to risk too much but maybe
hope for a small advantage so that's
kind of what i did and he generally goes
for this positions with black like the
symmetrical english so i thought there
might be a possibility i get it here one
certainly went right into us tell us
where he went wrong it seemed that
engines were throwing out equality at a
certain moment yeah right so um he
played well and then here perhaps knight
takes before is just a little bit
complicating its task i don't i wouldn't
say it's a bad move per se but e5 is a
clean way to equalize
and here you have to find a surprising
move f6 or if um or e5 and f6 and it's
not that
obvious for you because you want to get
some pieces developed so
that's what he did and i kind of thought
i remembered up to rook a4 but i guess i
was maybe perhaps wrong all of this prep
not too much i mean you can do a lot of
prep in a little time these days so
i i thought i knew of the rook a4 but i
might be mixing up there's a lot of
different setups and i didn't over
prepare something just i knew this idea
of route k4 like and the knight on b4 is
kind of a bit stuck let's say
um and then after short castles i was
going to play 94 and then i suddenly saw
bishop e3 and didn't see like where his
knight would go at all like i was going
to play here perhaps and then grab the
two bishop i'm actually blundering group
d4 oh okay it's very good i didn't do
this
i didn't serve before at all little
details of course for the audience the
bishop is hanging but also this thread
of knight d3 let's just move the bishop
somewhere knight d3 check of course
picks up that rook but a little bit of
luck and a ton of skill because bishop
e3 and it seemed that he couldn't answer
properly right i didn't see what he's
supposed to do well apparently there's
no like good solution anyway so i think
he's just in trouble here and after that
i thought i converted reasonably well
but i'm never too sure of course of
course in a rapid game you can't be so
sure but you ended up actually check
rating him yeah yeah an unusual
experience yeah that doesn't happen too
often but i think by that point it was
anyway losing i guess brilliant start
here in the rapid for you how's it feel
today
yeah just very good because i think i
played it last year and i won two games
in total so i'm already equal like in
that uh in that sense but of course um
you know it doesn't get any easier i
think i'm playing wesley with like the
next round so it's gonna be very tough
to continue like this of course going
three out of three though i doubt it but
i just take it as it goes and i'm
already very happy
regardless let's say absolutely well
you're the one for us with a great win
four out of four points remember that
rapids count for double games in 10
minutes let's go back to the studio
thank you thank you thank you